big expensive cities have a lot going
for them but if you live in one you've
probably noticed that these big
expensive cities keep getting more well
expensive you could always move away you
might have just started working remotely
so there's really nothing keeping you
there but then again moving is a hassle
well what if someone paid you 10 grand
to do it what if they threw in free
office space a bicycle or a gym
membership
programs in cities and states around the
us are doing exactly that and they're
getting a lot of interest we've had over
50 000 applications about 90 000
applications we've had over 1800
applicants from all over north america
so are these nascent programs actually
beneficial to their communities and the
workers joining them or are they little
more than flashy advertising campaigns
for places looking for an injection of
fresh talent
millions of americans migrate every year
but the coronavirus pandemic saw many
more people move out from urban areas
into smaller cities as remote work
allowed them to do their jobs from home
in fact more than 7 million households
moved to a different county in 2020
that's half a million more than the year
before
smaller cities across the us are seeing
this as an opportunity to attract
lifelong residents the remote incentive
programs that we're seeing pop up around
the country all go a little bit like
this a city that's looking to lure new
workers from other cities
offers a monetary incentive or a
cultural incentive for people to move
programs like this have exploded in
popularity around the us over the last
few years and their offerings are
getting more diverse in headline
grabbing as the pandemic prolongs the
richest cash offer comes out of uh west
virginia so there there's a little over
twenty thousand dollars that they're
offering twelve thousand in cash and
eight thousand in all kinds of amenities
so park membership
equipment rental they're really trying
to connect people to the outdoor wonders
of west virginia and they're using the
incentive to do that
offers like greensburg indiana they're
offering 5 000 of cash but really the
richness comes in their ability to sort
of connect you to the community they
offer things like a grandparents on
demand where a local couple will you
know babysit your kids for date night or
stand in for them uh at grandparents day
at school
that's evan hawk he co-founded
makemymove.com at the end of 2020 to
help those curious about moving just as
the recent uptick in remote work was
taking off
we rolled it out nationally about a year
ago here we've had over 40 000 people
register and are sort of actively
planning their moves on on the platform
as cities promote their best attributes
their incentive offerings are also
getting more creative how does a
thousand dollars at jimmy john's sound
or some free plots of land or our free
white water rafting or lift tickets more
your speed
for the first time in the country's
history there are tens of millions of
people that are geographical free agents
they're looking for
new homes and
that just means it's open season for
communities that are trying to grow
before digging into these programs let's
step back and ask what problem are they
trying to solve
for the most part they want highly paid
highly skilled workers to join their
ranks
it's a bit of a different model than
cities used to be using where they were
incentivizing with tax breaks or
kickbacks to whole companies to move you
know people would want an amazon to move
into their town so they could employ a
lot of local workers
well it makes sense they have the west
coast washington and the east coast
washington
alexa why should amazon build hq2 in
frisco
frisco texas thinks big we have blown up
our regulatory process over the last
couple years so that people who've come
to do business with us
know that we are open for business and
this is a kind of a twist on that model
where cities are looking at individual
workers that aren't necessarily going to
be employed in the local economy but are
going to be taking their salaries
spending at local restaurants buying
homes paying taxes and bringing their
kids and their partners and maybe their
family members
you can find the nation's busiest
program in tulsa oklahoma tulsa started
in 2018 before the pandemic before the
remote work way of life became so
widespread so they started with
about 75 people they've grown
exponentially over the past few years
what they realized is there's a big
problem with brain drain in tulsa a lot
of people go to universities in the
region and leave so what tulsa was
trying to do is stem that brain drain
there's over 1300 people in tulsa remote
now i mean we really are looking for
people that don't necessarily have a
mentality of them coming to change a
city you know more so
they want to be a part of something
awesome that's already happening we have
a weekly newsletter that goes out to our
members that highlights all the
different social events and gatherings
that we have we've got a slack community
that we post updates in there oftentimes
things are happening organically as well
with members ninety percent of the folks
that are done with their one year
commitment stay in tulsa beyond that
year
some programs like northwest arkansas
bitcoin and a bike incentive are
designed not for pulling in thousands of
new residents but to deliberately select
those with a set of specific qualities
to date we've got about 50
people on the ground that have taken
advantage of the incentive program how
to tell your spouse you're considering a
move to northwest arkansas step one
remind them of your vows
what we're trying to do is identify the
right types of talent and the reason why
is we have one of the strongest
economies in the country but it's built
primarily
on walmart tyson jb hunt there are 14
100 companies with presents here that
supply walmart right now they are
probably
they're
successful they're going to continue to
be successful but they're not going to
hire a lot more workers right every
region
they need more tech talent they need
more expertise in blockchain and so this
program is to really define those
key people that are going to help move
this region forward
for hawaii's program movers and shaka's
the goal isn't necessarily growing the
population at all
we are very focused on trying to bring
back returning kamaena which are people
who have lived in hawaii typically
refers to people who are born and raised
here
which is very different
which can include native hawaiians but
not necessarily our program is really
about bringing people to hawaii to learn
contribute and connect a goal of our
program isn't necessarily to have people
move to hawaii or move back to hawaii
although that would be awesome and we
have a couple examples of that
but it's really to build long-lasting
personal and professional ties and
relationships to hawaii
and what that does is reduce the
economic distance with the continent
aside from people taking advantage of
the programs themselves their mere
existence makes for good advertising
it's a climb
that's been started by so many
a climb taken by those who seek a life
less ordinary
maybe you already wanted to move and
maybe already your mom lives in savannah
georgia but you never thought it would
be possible to make that kind of move
and then you see savannah georgia
putting together this kind of package
and it gets back on your radar and for a
lot of the people that these programs
are are luring the ten thousand dollars
or five thousand dollars or whatever the
case may be
is maybe covering just the moving costs
but isn't enough to make you uproot your
entire life and move somewhere new so
far all of these programs are relatively
small compared to the populations of the
places in which they exist so while they
haven't caused too much fuss with locals
there's traffic jams now on some of the
main arterials we're just not used to
that so our patience level is not quite
there
there is always going to be a healthy
amount of skepticism to the arrival of
newcomers tulsa's program is funded with
philanthropic dollars um it's funded by
the george kaiser family foundation
which is this big philanthropy based in
town that's the same for northwest
arkansas
which is funded by another philanthropy
that's locally based it seems like
that's the dominant model so far but
some taxpayers have started to foot the
bill in other cities it's usually easier
to make the sell to the public that
you're giving money to outsiders when
it's not taxpayer money funding these
kinds of programs in northwest arkansas
there's a really large
urban rural divide there are a lot of
hourly workers they are paying tech
workers entrepreneurs ten thousand
dollars in bitcoin to move there there
is the sense among some that the money
could be better spent incentivizing
other things like
asking businesses to raise their minimum
wage i myself was a skeptic you know i
actually got this role
because of an op-ed that i wrote in the
star advertiser which is our local daily
newspaper
which was largely against the program
you know i was like why are we bringing
in
tech bros dripping with coven to come
and drive my rent up and destroy the
aloha spirit
when it came to hawaii i felt very
protective what i realized is that
that us first then kind of tribal
mentality
is very real and it's innate and we have
to acknowledge that it's there
and we also have to ask ourselves like
well how do we bring in newcomers you
know how do we see things as not a
zero-sum game
tulsa remote's justin harlan admits that
the program had some critics from the
local community but a recent independent
economic impact report estimates it's
brought in 62 million dollars in local
earnings into the city and added 600
jobs
for for many decades we've seen
export of talent out of a lot of
communities towards these big economic
centers and so one way to think about
this is a redistribution of a lot of
that economic impact
of course moving between cities can be a
huge lifestyle change and it's not
necessarily for everyone for a few weeks
ago it was literally snowing in the
backyard listen i moved to las vegas not
to have snow like that why i'm leaving
austin texas
it's it's really because of the lack of
diversity i'm also in a lot of facebook
groups and like all through the facebook
facebook groups people are like the
dating here is trash
[Music]
as for those big expensive cities
bleeding remote worker talent there
doesn't seem to be much to worry about
between march 2020 and february 2021 84
of movers in the u.s stayed in the same
metro area
in new york city the most popular place
people in manhattan moved to
brooklyn
in the end even if you personally don't
take part in or have any interest
whatsoever in one of these programs
there is an advantage for these places
to get their names out there
i think for a lot of cities they think
there's nothing really to lose despite
some of the questions about its efficacy
it doesn't really hurt
to say you know we're open to newcomers
where we're um
we're a place that we want to put on the
map
[Music]
you